hier le livre alors vous donne
énormément de conseil sport santé
hygiène de vie
mais ce qui m'a marqué c'est sont en
effet les moments où vous confiez
énormément notamment sur votre vie sur
vos défis vos angoisses votre
fécondation in vitro
est ce que ce livre ça vous a servi
finalement en fait de thérapie ce que ça
a été un besoin non la thérapie c'est
vraiment le sport
il m'a aidé pourquoi j'ai parlé de la
fécondation in vitro parce que j'ai eu
beaucoup de témoignages d'amis ou pas de
femme que je voyais en souffrance énorme
parce que c'est un vrai défi avec
d'avoir un bébé quand on peut pas en
avoir un et moi je l'avais je l'avais
vraiment abordés comme comme une
compétition ce moment là ouais vraiment
pas ce que c'est que des embûches et
j'avais envie de témoigner pour dire
d'abord les choses ont changé on le voit
quand on lit lité v de l'expert et oui
les filles c'est possible vous pouvez y
arriver sans vous effondrez sans y
laisser tout votre être votre couple
parce que ce qui est formidable dans le
livre effectivement c'est qu'à la fois
il ya des tma ni le témoignage perso
même avis que je sais ce que j'ai vécu
et il est corroborée et il va même
encore plus loin avec à chaque fois dans
chaque paragraphe
l'avis de l'expert l'avis de l'expert et
puis ensuite et vous quoi mais voilà
venez venez picorer venez choisir parce
que je suppose qu'il ya des mecs ça va
pas les intéresser du tout de le lire ça
banon mais papa pas forcément parce
qu'il ya aussi il ya eu le rapport à la
vie le rapport au corps le rapport au
sport mais je parlais de la fécondation
d'accord la passe quand même son départ
au 6 est une c'est une histoire de coup
là oui ça brise beaucoup de couples ces
histoires là donc oui merci j'avais très
envie que des experts donnent leurs
témoignages d'experts
emilie alors moi je suis un très mauvais
exemple c'est rare que je fais jamais de
sport et rien qu'en regardant votre
compte instagram je suis épuisé l'idée
c'est comment vous avez réussi à me
convaincre
ça fait bizarre de vous voyez aussi
quand vous avez réussi à me convaincre
de mettre au sport sans que au bout de
deux minutes janna ashe à faire en ce
que j'en ai ras-le-bol
parce que justement ce que j'explique
dans le livre c'est la base pour moi
c'est le plaisir pour faire du sport
pour être pour continuer à en faire
quand on en a jamais fait ou quand on
est voilà moi je n'aime pas le sport je
déteste courir vous faites très bien
aimé
en l'occurrence je te dirai pas ce que
j'ai envie de te tutoyer toi aussi tu
dirais tu aime danser
ouais elle affronte des cours de danse
salle et du sport ça va te permettre de
bouger c'est fatiguant comme pas
possible c'est vrai qu' un petit concept
rapport satisfaites et gréco donné quand
même mais revient en gros ça veut dire
nathalie de trouver parce que en gros ce
que vous nous dites ce que tu nous dis
c'est si vous allez faire du sport en
traînant la jambe en disant je n'aime
pas je le fais parce que je n'ai pas le
choix ça ne fonctionnera pas on va le
faire un mois deux mois puis s'est
terminée après absolument déjà s'en
tient deux mois c'est bien c'était pas
mal on a toujours le choix dans la vie
d'abord de faire ce qu'on veut moi je
fais pas non plus du prosélytisme à
tout-va je dis pas faux petit cette
histoire absolument non fais ce que tu
veux mais le sport va t'aider à aller
mieux le sport va t'aider à être plus
performant dans ton travail va t'aider à
être plus aimable dans ton couple dans
ta vie à sourire voilà le sport sa tête
pour beaucoup de choses dont on trouve
un moyen voilà etc ont trouvé un moyen
qui nous rend heureux quand même malgré
les malgré le fait qu'on soit là à
fatiguer un peu pour ça j'ai dit si tu
aime danser va danser ni donc quand tu
es sur le dancefloor connais bien et
quand aller sur le dancefloor elle un
mojito à la main
et je rappelle que l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé
kathryn morris et albert jean lavertue
très bien fait les choses de virgin chez
moi oui nathalie alors vous êtes
carrément addict aux sports on le
découvre en j'aime pas cette ce terme
parce que pourquoi la diction est
d'ailleurs sachez tout de l'accident à
pardon fait ma question est si forte
parce que peut-être vous n'aimez pas ce
mot mais c'est quand même ce qui ressort
du livre vous êtes addict aux sports
vous pouvez pas vous en passez vous en
faites du matin au soir
sa règle tous les problèmes de votre vie
est ce que j'allais vous dire c'est que
vous trouvez ça formidable mais ça reste
une addiction
donc c'est dangereux alors justement
bien sûr le livre je parle docteur jean
claude matysiak oui et addictologue et
je lui demande carrément est-ce que je
suis à dix et il répond eh bien non
nathalie tu n'es pas addict parce que
l'addiction
aujourd'hui on a un petit peu galvaudé
l'addiction au niveau qu'il ya quand
même un terme pour ça c'est la bigorre
et si et ça quand on fait quand on fait
de la bi goré xi c'est qu'on est on est
à dix addict on a absolument besoin dans
son équilibre
oui de faire du sport 1h 2h ce merdier
diktat où on dirait on dit addict à tous
les trucs et addictions ça veut dire
vraiment addiction ça veut dire ça va
serment que moi je n'y a pas de mention
ni drogué ni à moi je suis passionné par
le sport
mais vous savez le pas en faire pendant
des semaines et des semaines sans vous
dire à la semaine est une semaine c'est
un peu long mais je peux ne pas en faire
pendant 24 heures j'ai été blessé j'ai
pas pu faire de sport pendant quelques
mois j'en suis pas morte
oui la division c'est autre chose c'est
un domaine vraiment psychiatrique fin
lisez vous allez voir ce que dit
l'expert c'est clair oui
dans la vie on peut avoir des passions
on peut être un petit bilan je vais
changer la question allez vous poser une
question pour savoir comment on fait
pour ceux ne plus être addict aux sports
moi je culpabilise un convive est pas
mais je vais changer ma question vous
avez une silhouette est formidable et
nutritionnelle va pas être formidable
est-ce que c'est grâce au sport que vous
arrivez à conserver cette silhouette
formidable alors pour être honnête merci
papa merci maman quand même puisque j'ai
la chance d'avoir un bon métabolisme des
gènes certainement qui me permettent
d'être ce que je suis mais moi je
considère qu'on est tous des ferrari et
que
si on met de la mauvaise naissance
pourri dans la ferrari la ferrari n a
pas avancé d'accord voilà je le lis
viennent de vie c'est un tout c'est
judas manche c'est ce qu'on se dépense
c'est prendre soin de soi cm tout
simplement oui c'est faire ses courses
en regardant ce qu'on va manger parce
que comme disait qu'au fond nous fait
manger de la merde mais la raison voilà
c'est être attentif être un acteur de sa
vie plutôt qu'un spectateur